nächster redner hier in der debatte die
generalaussprache jetzt fängt sozusagen
eine neue runde nachdem alle
fraktionschefs der verschiedenen
fraktionen schon zu wort gekommen sind
jetzt die zweite runde und die beginnt
die afg hat ja eine zweiten
fraktionschef in dem fall eine chefin
mit alice weiter präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe brinkhaus
ich habe selten so eine unkonkrete rede
von ihnen gehört das waren nur hohle
phrasen sie sind nicht einmal konkret
geworden ich weiß sie können es besser
ich weiß noch nicht ob das mit ihren job
zusammenhängt vor dem die
fraktionsvorsitzender sind und liebe
frau merkel
liebe frau merkel
ein gleichzeitiger ausstieg aus atom und
kohlekraft ist nicht nur
unverantwortlich sondern lang hier sind
dann nützt auch kein wir schaffen das
und wem sie komplett aus den augen
verloren haben in konkreten das sind
jetzt mittlerweile von ihnen gewohnt ist
der steuerzahlende bürger für die ganz
normalen bürger die jeden morgen
aufstehen ihre kinder versorgen
zur arbeit fahren steuern zahlen und
dieses gemeinwesen am laufen halten gibt
es an diesem haushalt nicht viel zu
feiern zu übergehen auch diesmal dass
dieser haushalt mit diesem rekordvolumen
nur dadurch möglich ist dass sie den
bürgern viel zu tief in die tasche
greifen und das flickwerk
der teil abschaffung des
solidaritätszuschlages ist symptomatisch
dafür 90 prozent der steuerzahler werden
entlastet sagen sie aber die hälfte des
ungerechtfertigt eingetriebenen geldes
also gute zehn milliarden euro wollen
sie weiter behalten und verstoßen damit
gegen die verfassung um es ganz klar zu
sagen und dabei ist steuergerechtigkeit
ganz einfach ganz einfach schaffen sie
den solo denen so die ab für alle jetzt
dieses zeichen dass wir den auch noch
vergehen schaffen sie den sony ab für
alle jetzt und sofort und nicht erst im
übernächsten jahr vor den wahlen
das ist unsere forderung und dabei
bleiben wir
um was der staat zu viel einnimmt muss
den bürgern zurückgegeben werden
gerade weil deutschland in die rezession
schlittert müssen die fesseln gelockert
werden
durch eine senkung und vereinfachung des
einkommens steuersatzes ohne
mittelstandsbauch und kalte progression
durch eine deutliche senkung und
vereinfachung der umsatzsteuer die
konsumenten mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen am stärksten belastet und
durch den ausbau des ehegattensplitting
zum familiensplitting um der
steuerlichen benachteiligung von eltern
entgegen zu wirken
die spielräume dafür sind da das
gesamtsteueraufkommen der öffentlichen
hand hat sich unter ihrer regierung seit
2005 auf gegenwärtig rund 900 milliarden
euro jahr verdoppelt es wird ja immer
verdoppelt aber dieses geld wird falsch
ausgegeben und sie haben diese
milliarden zum größten teil
verkonsumiert und die infrastruktur
verfallen lassen statt dort zu
investieren wo es notwendig ist und sie
haben unser land mit den drei großen
fehlentscheidungen die als die drei groß
rechtsbrüche in die geschichte eingehen
werden in die sackgasse manövriert und
mit der unbedingten euro rettung der
unkontrollierten einwanderung und der
grünen populistischen energiewende das
kann man nicht anders sagen
und statt diese fehlentscheidungen zu
korrigieren versuchen sie die folgen
verzweifelt zu überdecken
die viel gepriesene schwarze null ist
letztlich nur der massen enteignung von
bürgern und sparern durch die
nullzinspolitik der ezb zu verdanken
sie können sich ihren haushalt schön
rechnen weil der bund keine zinsen mehr
auf seine schulden zahlt den preis
zahlen stattdessen die bürger durch
fortgesetzte massive wohlstandsverluste
und nachdem sparbücher und
lebensversicherung bereits als
anlageform ruiniert sind wollen sie als
nächstes die käufer von aktien fonds
über eine finanztransaktionssteuer
schröpfen die nur die kleinen sparer und
anleger trifft so sieht die politik der
groko für die arbeitende bevölkerung aus
sie machen private vorsorge unmöglich
gleichzeitig ist die steuerlast für
neurentner in der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung seit 2010 bis auf das
fünffache angestiegen die euro rettung
und der unersättliche steuerstaat
schaffen die altersarmut die sie
anschließend beklagen und die
nachgelagerte besteuerung von renten ist
widersinnig und unsozial und sie muss
umgehend abgeschafft werden wer vor
negativ
in riskantere anlagen vorangetrieben
wird der soll künftig seine verluste
nicht mehr steuerlich geltend machen
können sogar rückwirkend nicht das muss
man sich mal vorstellen
und damit nicht genug anonyme goldkäufe
sollen drastisch eingeschränkt werden
es stehen forderungen im raum dass sie
darüber lachen dass wir völlig klar
lachen sie nur er steht förderung im
raum größere fahrgeschäfte generell
meldepflichtig zu machen oder enge
grenzen für verkäufe zu ziehen aber
bargeld ist freiheit sie aber führend
krieg gegen die finanzielle freiheit den
persönlichen datenschutz und stellen
bürger die ihre freiheitsrechte
wahrnehmen wollen unter einen
generalverdacht besitzen nämlich aus und
der meinungsfreiheit haben sie eben auch
den krieg erklärt der flop mit dem netz
dg war ihnen noch nicht genug sie wollen
dieses unselige gesetz auch noch
ausweiten meldepflicht für
netzwerkbetreiber eine ganz neue behörde
das können sie ja so gut die auf der
basis von gummiparagraphen wie hass und
hetze meinungsäußerung filtern und zur
anklage bringen soll
das klingt nach orwell und so ist es
wohl auch gemeint abweichende
meinungsäußerungen werden kriminalisiert
das ist ihr plan und so kann man
natürlich auch die repräsentation
demokratie abschaffen und man kann sie
heimlich aushebeln
nicht umsonst interessieren sich letzter
zwiebel regimes wie weißrussland für das
netz dg und für ihre internet
schnüffelgesetz der generalangriff auf
die wirtschaftliche freiheit findet im
übrigen auch unter dem begriff
klimaschutz statt
sie bedienen sich dazu einer radikalen
minderheit wir hören das brummen hiervon
klima apocalyptica wohlstands
verwahrloste öko marxisten so nennt die
neue zürcher zeitung thema schweiz auch
darauf reiten sie ja immer um ein klima
von panik und ausnahmezustand zu
schaffen
das dient als rechtfertigung für neue
steuern wie zb der co2 bepreisung für
neue verbote gängelung und massive
eingriffe im private freiheits und
eigentumsrechte es gibt keinen
klimaschutz statt verantwortungsvoller
und sparsamer umgang mit unseren
ressourcen ist dringend geboten ebenso
die freie erforschung neuer technologien
aber was sie als klimaschutz propagieren
ist pure ideologie
es ist keine frage von leben
oder tod sondern von freiheit oder
sozialismus zukunftstechnologien im
übrigen werden auch nicht am grünen
tisch erfunden wie sie sich das
vorstellen aber milliarden an
subventionen wurden bereits sinnlos in
die energiewende gesteckt aber
milliarden für elektromobilität sollen
folgen
und damit soll eine nicht
wettbewerbsfähige technologie erst
wettbewerbsfähig gemacht werden die
subventionen verzerren und behindern den
wettbewerb und die freie entfaltung
innovativer kräfte sie führen zu
fehlallokation von kapital die folgen
dieser politik werden wir noch
jahrzehntelang ausbaden müssen und die
kaskade von stellenstreichungen bei
automobil energie und chemie unternehmen
ist erst der anfang
20.000 jobs weg bei continental 15.000
bei bosch 10.000 bei mercedes 9500 bei
audi 7000 bei vw 3000 bei basf und die
liste lässt sich lang fortsetzen
und das ist nur die spitze des eisberges
der jobabbau setzt sich nämlich über die
gesamte wertschöpfungskette fort es
trifft den produktiven kern der
deutschen wirtschaft es trifft die
hersteller von investitionsgütern die
anlagenbauer kleine und kleinste
zulieferer in der fläche und das ist das
fatale durch ihre subventionspolitik
finanzieren die steuerzahler ihren
arbeitsplatzverlust nämlich selbst und
das ist das für unverantwortliche an
ihrer regierungspolitik
die rot rot grün
berlin derzeit in wohnungsmarkt mit
mietobergrenzen enteignungsdrohung und
faktischen einheits medien ruiniert ist
von ddr verhältnissen nicht mehr weit
entfernt
was die spd auf bundesebene plant ist
nicht besser massive eingriffe in das
privateigentum durch mieten deckel und
einschränkungen bei der umlegung von
modernisierungskosten und die
grundsteuer stadt diese anachronistische
steuer abzuschaffen wird sie als
vorstufe der enteignung genutzt um
eigentum unrentabel zu machen und der
plan der bundesregierung besitzer von
eigentumswohnungen auch gegen ihren
willen zu dem maßnahmen oder zum bau von
elektroautos ladesäulen zu zwingen
schlägt in dieselbe kerbe das muss man
sich mal vorstellen was hier forderten
sie bitter wie er redet sein ein
prosperierendes industrie hat das sich
derart kopflos dem ast des eigenen
wohlstandes absägt macht sich zum
gespött der welt bitte klären sie um von
ihrem fatalen irrweg weil die
fraktionsvorsitzende der afd
[Applaus]